Hi my name is Randy Keefe, and I'm from Santiago
California. I graduated from Linfield Christian
School in 2012, and I'm currently a Political
Economy major at Hillsdale College. This spring
I'm interning for the Council for National
Policy as part of the Washington Hillsdale
Internship Program.The Washington Hillsdale
Internship Program, we
call it WHIP for short, we bring anywhere
between ten to twenty students a semester
out to DC. They take two or three classes
and they intern on the hill, at the Heritage
Foundation, really anywhere they want to.
When we find somebody coming out of college
who has some practical real world experience,
especially experience that applies to what
we do, it really sets them apart. Washington
is one of those places that kids can learn
a lot and gain a lot just from being hear
a few moths. And in that since, coming here
and having that interning experience I guarantee
will be life changing.